[Music]
guys i have a story
of this woman only known as madame w
because she's a pen she actually did
something
really generous and really kind so
she she released her people so she had
this fortune
by the way she's anonymous so i don't
know anything about her you know what a
w stands for
wealthy madam wealthy exactly because
she left
a portion of her multi-million
dollar fortune to several orphanages
in malaysia when she died in 2013 but
she didn't do it as a one-off payment to
these orphanages
what she did is she set up an estate
and that and held a trust for the sole
purpose
of investment which those earnings would
be given to these orphanages
lifelong payments yes that's genius so
you don't teach a man to fish
no you don't give a man no no no no you
don't teach
you give him about the fish you buy him
a fish no no you
oh yeah actually yeah endlessly give
them fish
yeah so you don't teach them because the
orphans don't know how to make the money
or the orphanage it's
you set them up for endless supply of
fish
but it's not a man that you're giving a
fish to his children because
you know a band could learn how to fish
on his own i guess children technically
can't
you don't teach our children to fish you
just give the [ __ ] out of them
that's dope yeah isn't that amazing so
yeah so these orphans got rolexes and
stuff no that's not that crazy
because like for example manager of the
orphanage i see yeah
that was like they started like rolling
up in like nice ass cars and like the
kids don't get [ __ ]
that's funny because they don't do that
that would [ __ ] suck yeah
hopefully hopefully it's the other way
what about the kids man what about the
kids
yeah so i mean this is in malaysia right
so different currencies they're saying
that
since her death in 2013 her donations
have totaled
1.1 million malaysian ringgit which come
out to
263 1557. that's a dollar yeah that's
a lot of moolah man man they probably
eat the best roti
oh it's so good over there
so she left like a few million dollars
in
investments that pay dividends to these
okay
yeah so she just wanted to have her
money work for itself
and continuously benefit these
orphanages that's smart
compared to like she's 20 orphanages by
the way that's a lot
i don't understand rich people that want
to be anonymous
why who do we think god damn it
that's what i'm saying madam w just have
to thank your blessings
nah that ain't right somebody set that
[ __ ] up it wasn't the spirits
yeah because in america you can't wait
like yes the almost the steps are
you ball out right of course you spend
it on yourself then you start doing
philanthropy
and then after that and you still have
too much money then it's about legacy
so you go to any of the colleges they're
named after
some baller ass dude and they also set
up like a trust fund to create
scholarships
like in that case like because for me
personally my
own opinion on that is that in that
in that case it doesn't feel as genuine
as if it was anonymously done because to
me it just feels like you just
you let the work speak for itself you
don't you just can't win in america
though
feel don't mean [ __ ] if you're dead
though right well that's what i'm saying
like
but then if this was i'll take it for
granted if it just was given to me and i
didn't know who gave it to me
if i was dying it's like a free lunch at
the school right you just kind of like
who's paying for this lunch but you know
that madam w
gave it to you you don't know who she is
you don't know so it's like a superhero
alias
that's at least someone that you can
think i my
dumb brain needs a folklore character
you know what i mean like
superman that's what focus
there you go yeah but let's create this
person wonder woman right wonder
yeah it's madam wonder woman yeah wonder
woman
what if it's guilt money create
something man sorry what my my brain
she's good
maybe she could could be a snakehead
heroin dealer right
she could have robin hood it yeah you
know what i'm saying it's like guilt
money so you're like hey i'm gonna be
anonymous
yeah it's dirty money right like that
but not necessarily guilty
because it's like robin hood style yeah
you got it in america you can't do that
unless like you're about to die or like
you die
what what give money so it's like a few
reasons
right because then say you do it
anonymously right
people you're talking about a certain
amount of money anything
because i mean in case you could give me
ten dollars right now we're good
that's different donating right because
then they're like oh you're just doing
it to like
show that you're like you think you're
like we're bragging about it or like
you're doing this like people are going
to hate you no matter what right
if you don't you do anonymously people
are going to be like where the [ __ ] why
aren't you doing you didn't do anything
you didn't do anything they're like
[ __ ] i did all this stuff and they're
like oh now you want to brag about it
and now you want to use for clout
yeah and it's like i did keep it secret
first that's true you're wrong either
way
that's true i mean that's why like in
this specific specific case where it's
like
if i'm adam w i'm dying it i don't care
what people think of me i don't care if
they thought i didn't do anything good
for other people at least
i know that i did and i don't need the
praise for it that's good
i mean cool i think either way it's like
if you're gonna die and like it comes
out say like after your death
i feel like it's either having it
attached to a name or not
is good because in one it's like people
can live oh damn like she literally did
this out of the kindness of her heart
because she's dying
she's not getting the gratification like
unless you think about like your legacy
after that
i get curious though she just needs like
one quote after her name madam w it's
got like madame w
may those who benefit from this always
give to others as they have been given
to you
you know that's nice let's just assume
that's what she meant
that's but in malaysia dude i'm
malaysian yeah i would like mata w
get paid [ __ ] [ __ ] that'd be tight
that would be super fun
then all the orphans grow up it's like
getting paid [ __ ]
[ __ ] get paid [ __ ] [ __ ] that's like
the motto at the orphanage like on a
plaque in the hallways
and what do we do today kids get paid
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and then they do [ __ ] tick-tock and
[ __ ] hey [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's like a tribute to madame w sitting
over here just like i'm just like yeah
if that's what madam w wanted we can't
argue
well i don't hear a proper woman when i
hear madame i feel like
she's like a gangster boss like that's
pretty good like madame harold dumb
yeah you know she's like she's like the
biggest human smuggler
in the [ __ ] trying like the arc the
golden triangle you know and she smokes
cigarettes out of like those sticks that
have like extra sticks and whole
cigarettes
and she wears like army fatigue and
she's always posing with the ak-47 and
[ __ ]
i wasn't thinking about camouflage what
that's what they call them
fatigues yeah i don't know that they
tire you out yeah i think they're tired
i don't know
but what about the rich kids i think if
i die i'll donate to the rich kids why
because they need it right they need it
too sometimes true
why they left out yeah i live right
about the rich kids come on
so with your money just leave it to
taika yeah
what's mad why does her bee damn you
have like no
nostril hairs for reals
so random put them all out do you use
that one that kid that's like why are
you fat
dude honestly it gave me a glimpse of
like whoa now i have a joe on this side
it's a joke thing it just looks so like
if you like are super rich
and you're about to dine you got no
relieved to so you like donate to people
in need
if you're like not super rich and you
have like hella debt and you're about to
can you like give that to like super
rich people when someone
goes to your kids yeah but if you don't
have any children if i could get the
restaurant bill right before die
it's yours
dude you know it's interesting because i
started thinking about this and i'm like
you know what it reminded me of we went
to the strip club and
like we were making it rain yeah uh
everyone like
julia was making rain and
on those glittery orphans huh yup no the
fake
the one that we shot the the show no uh
we went to vegas and
yeah yeah with the orphans
and then for some reason i don't know
why i do this but
i would give the stripper money when she
wasn't looking at me
and so like an anonymous donation
you know they're richer than you though
that's the thing in vegas it's not i'm
not trying to like help her out or
whatever oh
i'm just like i just realized like she's
not getting recognition for it doing it
when she's looking yeah
was it because you felt like you felt
bad for doing it no no
she's not going to come downstairs at
the right time did you want her to
acknowledge you
when you were giving her money no the
thing is i i
subconsciously i did not want to be
recognized for
giving her money for some reason i
didn't want her to know that i gave her
money
in that particular transaction that's
called a bad return of investment i know
i understand that when she
sees that she comes to you and she
twerks it i understand that but for me
i'm like you're doing your
your your good job already like you
don't need to come and give me extra for
the tip
i dance every day and you don't stop by
and i'm not
going to never dance in front of me like
that i'll face this way
there you go where's the money
that's a lot of money smack the back of
your head stack
how would you feel if like we showed up
to when you're practicing we started
throwing money
your friends didn't know who we were
it's going to turn into kinja dales
would that be considered disrespectful
it depends if it's like
crumpled smelly one dollar but it's a
lot of them
no i'll be fine with it it's never
disrespectful when it's money
it's just it's still currency that would
hurt
at our old apartment it was expensive to
live there but there was hella strippers
that lived there oh yeah
our uh the guy that downstairs that what
do you call them they probably pay with
cash but it's cheaper
the doorman would uh accompany them
because that was the building blue that
was attached to the wells fargo
just right outside the door the atm and
who'd like every day thousands of
dollars from the same people
wow it's going into the you mean they
probably pay with cash
yeah yeah from their tips they're
balling so
the strippers would tip the guys no uh
the stripper would have the doormat
uh like so they could deposit right yeah
to protect them
so the escort would need an escrow like
a bodyguard kind of yeah it's going into
an escort
wow thousands of dollars every single
day you would say
what do you mean thousands of dollars
everything you would depo she would
deposit thousands of dollars from her
work she
made like two two three four five g's
and she was depositing that
every day oh so the concierge was
helping
them not get robbed with the atm not get
robbed
yeah you didn't add the atm park man
that was the first thing you see
there's a wells fargo connected to the
building oh i didn't hear that
like you need it more than i did i do
there's
no way someone's gonna hire me dude if i
didn't [ __ ] run [ __ ]
i would probably never be working it's
one or the other dude
[Music]
yeah it is yeah if you think about it
joe would never
man i try to get job interviews nobody
wanted i wouldn't be working
[Laughter]
i wish the conference i have now going
into a job interview
like i would i would want to but not
actually work for them but see if they
would hire me
i feel like you should sign up for
something that feels like telephone dude
that's like an ego boost yeah i'll get
hired on the spot
the problem is does the person
understand my value because they're
[ __ ] stupid well that's why i would
i don't know how are you getting hired
on the spot if they don't like you say
be like okay this is for costco i made a
multi-million dollar business i run
these many accounts i make this one
they'll laugh at you because you're
lying you you can't go in there without
trying to be the guy that stands in the
front and like mark receipts at costco
or what do you think yeah right
that's [ __ ] dude you got to know
your role you got to go in the you got
to go
just be like i want to humble myself i
do this but i want to get a job you go
you say i just graduated from long beach
city college
um i have uh i was a president of the
key club um
do they got a key club i don't know but
gamma data fata that was my frat
we did it we did a lot of gamut data
theta gamma beta data
what's it what's data
it's a tech company
[Laughter]
[Music]
data
[Music]
you